not gonna lie after watching this movie
I wanted to go out and get some Formula
One racing games or at least play some
Mario Kart which I will there we go old
school with the Mario Kart rush so rush
is a movie directed by Ron Howard about
a rivalry in Formula One racing between
two drivers named niki lauda and James
Hunt you know me I love a good rivalry
Ron Howard's a good director should be a
good movie turns out it was a good movie
I really liked the rivalry between these
two guys but they're so contrasted
they're so different James Hodge is just
one of those you live it up you know
he's here for the fun of it tomorrow you
might die and he's completely willing to
die so it's like hey have fun
he's the in he is the walking ed then
you had the Austrian niki lauda he's
like no you gotta think smart take
emotion out of it see it all as math it
makes you a safe driver it makes you a
better driver and I will beat you these
two are like the Mozart and Salieri of
the racetrack
although Mozart was better than Salieri
and these two are pretty evenly matched
in their own ways and their own passions
it's just a movie about two guys who
want to be great they want to leave
their mark on the earth and in doing so
life will give them that little bonus of
beating the other guy he would almost
think hey these two would probably have
a good time going out and getting a beer
together just shooting the [ __ ] fact is
that's not going to happen because just
the sight of the others face infuriates
them another thing this movie does well
is these two were even in your mind's
eye neither one is the villain just two
guys two different perspectives two
different ways of going about one goal
so in that sometimes you're like ah
James Hunt he's got a right you know
like screw that niki louder guy James
Hunt's the man another times you're like
Niki Lauda is a badass you know James
Hunt's you're not as cool as Niki Lauda
he's pretty awesome I yeah you don't
understand you just don't understand
what a movie can make me flip-flop like
that make me feel like I don't have
conviction in my own opinion that's not
a bad thing props of that movie and of
course the racing is intense and badass
to the revving up the cars you see the
Pistons like dude do you still um own
[ __ ] and you're like yes it has gotten
real now not much I didn't like about
the movies funny because I'm not a
Formula one guy don't like I sit down on
the most boring ass day of the week
Sunday turn on racing book oh thank god
something good is on today not how I am
I'm like oh that's boring other wipeouts
happening no wipeouts I I'm out but this
movie makes me care about Formula One
racing I want to google it I want to
find out all about the sport I guess
what I'm trying to convey is you don't
have to be a race car kind of guy to
enjoy this movie any more than you need
to be an MMA guy to enjoy the movie
warrior it's not about the sport the
sport is a means to tell a story and the
story is told really well these two
characters are awesome the rivalry was
badass I thought they were great I
walked on a rush with nothing but
satisfaction because Rush is awesome
tacular rush is just it's a sexy movie
if I could say it like that I don't know
if it was all the attractive ass people
hung screen or the infection or the hot
chicks or Olivia Wilde just the speed
rivalry the tension for some odd reason
I was just watching this movie with half
a stack the entire time and I was like
this it's not a bad day for me and if
you're thinking to yourself that doesn't
make any sense that guy on YouTube sit
[ __ ] you're gonna be watching rush
you're gonna think to yourself yeah this
is one sexy ass movie there's something
about it I'm just saying it's there so
rush have you seen what did you think
about it and what's your favorite racing
movie out there think hard on that one
there's more than fast in the Furious
there is more than what is just fast and
what is just various so whatever it
would be comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you